I need somebody do you were your first
memory of them and where you saw them
when they perform first I think he was
on Ed Sullivan I watched that it was so
important everybody to me I mean it was
amazing and my birthday my tenth
birthday
what I wanted was Beatle boots and a
beat away are you kidding my parents
couldn't find Beatle boots but I got you
down at the dime store Woolworths or
some place they got it they found a
beetle wig
the director is putting that beetles
loved to work directing a new
documentary which includes newly
discovered homies and bootlegs sound
both digitally enhanced top British
group top records of the year yes some
little magic chemistry that happened
between us seems to appeal to each
generation as it comes in
here are the directors to read takeaways
first the Beatles basically invented the
stadium tour out of necessity the police
and local governments told them that
they continue to play 10,000 person
arenas that they'd always have 30 or
40,000 people outside kids outside
clamoring they couldn't control it
second they stood up to segregation I
didn't know that their first political
stand the first big controversial issue
involved what was to be a segregated
concert in Jacksonville Florida and they
said are you kidding me that's
ridiculous
they couldn't see the logic in it of
course but they had no idea how
controversial it was but they stuck to
their guns and three the Beale story
just feels like a Hollywood movie book
it's we were all pretty scary it's this
ensemble tale of these young guys
they're boys at the beginning they're
men at the end and they've been through
an amazing journey and the world not
just the country of the United States
but the world has gone through a
transformative period as well
you